.
I'M HOPING THAT PRESIDENT DOES
NOT FALL INTO THAT TRAP.
>> Rachel: YOU MIGHT TRY TO
SHAKE HIS HAND.
>> LET'S BRING IN TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL.
>> Pete: YOU BY DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLICANS ASIDE AND YOU TRY TO
SECURE THE BORDER.
THE PEOPLE THAT PUT YOU IN
OFFICE.
YOU HAVE SOME COMPANY THIS TIME
AND WANTS TO KEEP TITLE 42
AROUND FROM YOUR PARTY.
KYRSTEN SINEMA, SENATOR KELLY.
WHY IS THE PRESIDENT NOT
LISTENING?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
YOU CAN'T SAY WE HAVE A PANDEMIC
OR A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE HERE.
BUT THEN SAY EVERYTHING IS FINE
AT THE BORDER AND THEN LIFT THE
TITLE 42 WHICH IS A HEALTH
ORDER.
YOU JUST CAN'T HAVE BOTH.
WE KNOW LIKE YOU SAID A FEW
MINUTES AGO, 221,000 PEOPLE THIS
LAST MONTH AND CERTAINLY RIGHT
NOW, THE CARTELS ARE LOOKING AT
TITLE 42.
THE MOMENT THEY LOOKED AT, YOU
WILL SEE A LOT MORE PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS.
>> IS NONTHING.
IT'S JARRING.
IT'S GOT TO BE FRUSTRATING FOR
YOU, CONGRESSMAN IS A MEMBER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO SEE
POLITICIANS AT THE VERY TOP OF
YOU SEEM TO NOT WANT TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM.
ULTIMATELY, THERE ARE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN WE DO
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT WE ARE
NOW GETTING INFORMATION THAT IN
2021, THERE WERE 23 KNOWN OR
SUSPECTED TERRORIST CAUGHT AT
THE U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER IN 2021
ALONE.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT ON THE ONES WE CAN
ACTUALLY DO A BACKGROUND CHECK
ON.
THAT IS NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT ENCOUNTERED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS A SERIOUS NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
>> IN THE OLD DAYS, IT WAS
MEXICANS COMING INTO, AND LOOK
FOR WORK AND THEY WOULD GO BACK
TO THE COUNTRY WITH THE MONEY
THAT THEY MADE.
AND YOU START SEEING ABOUT 12 OR
14 YEARS AGO, CENTRAL AMERICANS
COMING IN.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING FROM 50-60
COUNTRIES ALL ACROSS THE WORLD.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOING TO COME
IN WITH BAD INTENTIONS.
THAT IS WHAT WORRIES ME.
ONE MORE THING, IF YOU TALK A
BORDER PATROL, THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE BORDER PATROL, ONLY 40% OF
THE MEN AND WOMEN ARE ACTUALLY
DOING WORK AT THE BORDER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY, IN THE 50-60%
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT THERE
DOING WORK.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
60% IN BOTH OF THOSE SECTORS
RIGHT NOW, THEIR MEN AND WOMEN
ARE CHANGING --
MAKING FOOD WHEN I MIGRANTS.
THEY DON'T BELONG THERE.
WE ARE ONLY WORKING WITH 40% OF
OUR PERSONNEL BORDER PATROL.
DON'T YOU KNOW THAT YOU CAN BET
THAT THE BAD GUYS KNOW THIS.
>> Rachel: THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE PAID FOR.
THEY DIDN'T PAY FOR BORDER
PATROL CHANGING DIAPERS OR
PROCESSING PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
SECURING THE BORDER IN DOING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WORK.
HERE'S ANOTHER CASE IF YOU ASK
ME.
AMERICANS SAY THEIR TAXES
YESTERDAY.
NOW WE FIND OUT THAT THE DHS
BLUE $17 MILLION ON UNUSED HOTEL
ROOMS FOR MIGRANTS.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER SLAP IN THE
FACE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
CONGRESSMAN, CONGRESSMAN.
>> WHENEVER THEY ENTER INTO
THOSE CONTRACTS, THEY HAVE TO DO
A BETTER JOB IN NEGOTIATING,
BECAUSE LOOK, WHEN YOU SAY, HEY,
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY ME FOR THIS
BLOCK OF ROOMS WHETHER THEY ARE
USED ARE NOT USED, WE JUST HAVE
TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
NEGOTIATING.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT GOT
GIVEN IS IT WAS THE FACT THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW THIS LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS.
YES, WE DID.
WE JUST HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB
IN NEGOTIATING THOSE CONTRACTS.
>> IT WAS A SOLE-SOURCE CONTRACT
OR THE GOVERNMENT WAS OBLIGATED
TO PAY THE $17 MILLION FOR HOTEL
ROOMS THAT WERE NOT USED.
WHY DO YOU SIGN CONTRACTS LIKE
THAT?
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER.
>> CONGRESSMAN, THE MAIN THING
IS WE HAVE POLICIES THAT DIDN'T
WORK AND ONES THAT DID WORK.
THIS IS A NONPOLICY.
THERE IS NO POLICY AT THE BORDER
EXCEPT FOR TO OVERWHELM THE
BORDER PATROL AND DIMINISH
I.C.E. AND THEIR NUMBERS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB.
WHAT IS BEHIND THIS?
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A POLICY OF
DEBATE.
THEY ARE M.I.A.
WHAT IS BEHIND IT?
>> YOU HAVE TO ASK THEM.
>> Brian: THEY DON'T ASK YOU
BECAUSE I DON'T ANSWER YOUR
CALLS.
THEY DON'T COME TO VISIT YOU.
THEY ASK WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> CERTAINLY, AS A VICE CHAIRMAN
OF APPROPRIATIONS SUBCOMMITTEE,
YOU KNOW, WE CERTAINLY HAVE PUT
OUR -- WHAT WE HAVE DONE AS WE
TRY TO PUT AS MUCH MONEY AS WE
CAN.
BUT THEY, YOU KNOW, THEIR
MOTIVES, YOU HAVE TO ASK THEM.
I CAN TELL YOU, IN TALKING TO
THE MEN AND WOMEN IN GREEN, AND
I WANT TO HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
D.C. COME IN AND HAVING A PAT ON
THE BANK.
THEY WANT SOMEONE TO REALLY HAVE
THEIR BACK.
RIGHT NOW, WHEN YOU TALK TO MEN
AND WOMEN IN GREEN AND BLUE,
THEY FEEL DEMORALIZED.
IT'LL FEEL THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
BACK.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE THAN GIVE
THEM A PAT ON THE BACK.
THE OTHER 60% OF THE BORDER
PATROL, THE 2 SECTORS I
MENTIONED, THEY WANT TO BE OUT
THERE SECURING THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE CHANGING
THE DIAPERS AND ALL THAT.
AND WE'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND AND
ONE MORE THING, LOOK, IT'S OKAY
TO LISTEN TO IMMIGRATION
ACTIVISTS WHEN THIS POLICY HAS
BEEN MADE.
HE WAS LISTENING TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN GREEN?
WHO'S LISTENING TO THE MAYORS
AND JUDGES OUT THERE?
YOU'VE GOT TO LISTEN TO THE
BORDER COMMUNITY AND TO THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN GREEN.
>> Rachel: THEY ARE MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY OUT THIS SITUATION
AS WELL.
THAT'S ANOTHER PART OF THE
STORY.
THE OTHER PART OF IT,
CONGRESSMAN, IS YOUR OWN PARTY
IS LEADING HISPANIC VOTERS
BECAUSE OF THIS CHAOS AT THE
BORDER.
I APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US
TODAY.
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN HONEST
BROKER ON THIS I